[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: So let's
talk about Flutter.
Our vision for Flutter is
something that many of us
have been dreaming of for years.
A powerful, general
purpose, open UI toolkit
for building stunning
experiences on any device.
Embedded, mobile,
desktop, or beyond.
There are four
characteristics of Flutter
that we think make it a
unique platform for you
to build native mobile
application experiences.
Firstly, Flutter enables
you to build beautiful apps.
Flutter provides a rich palette
of tools that give you control
over every pixel on the screen.
Secondly, Flutter is fast.
It's powered by the blazing
speed Skia 2D graphics
engine which enables hardware
accelerated graphics.
Thirdly, Flutter is productive.
Flutter introduces a
revolutionary new capability
for developers and designers
to iterate on their apps
in real time.
And lastly, Flutter is open.
Flutter itself is open source,
open for contributions,
open for extendability.
Every line of code
is available for you
to read, fork, extend, amend.
Put all this
together and you have
Flutter, a framework
for building
beautiful, native experiences
for iOs or Android
from a single code base.
SPEAKER 2: So we built
an app for this event.
It's called The
History of Everything.
And I'm going to give you
a little tour of the app.
This is because Flutter compiles
ahead of time to arm code.
All right, so there is no
[INAUDIBLE] to warm up.
There are no scripts to parse.
So let's take this
a little further.
It's nice to have scrolling.
But how can we
turn this up to 11?
So I'm going to zoom right past
dinosaurs, because it turns out
nobody likes dinosaurs.
I can sway the tree
above of Newton.
And here we have an iPhone
from 2013, so five years ago.
And again, it runs just fine.
But can we take it
a little further?
Let me zoom in.
Oh, is this an actual
Google map running
inside my Flutter application?
[APPLAUSE]
While it's being swayed around.
You know, sure.
We've seen an application
that I think is beautiful
that was built in three
months by three people that
is fast on a wide
range of devices,
and that because of
the openness of Flutter
can do cool things like this.
SPEAKER 3: I'm so
excited to tell you today
why I believe that Flutter
is the perfect platform
for executing pixel
perfect designs.
Right now, good
design is expensive.
The designer hands us something
detailed and beautiful.
But we push back on
what makes it special.
We end up compromising
on the details that
make our experience excellent.
So with the best of intentions,
we say we'll get to it later.
But let's be honest.
Later never comes.
We've looked closely
at what developers
need to execute
complex, high fidelity
designs on the devices of today,
and put it at their fingertips.
We can ship the app we
really want with detail
and polish and fewer of
those painful compromises.
These are reusable widgets
designed by the material design
team here at Google.
We released a major
expansion of material,
making the system more
flexible and expressive.
You also get Cupertino,
the faithful implementation
of Apple's iOs design language.
Cupertino gives us
action sheets, alerts,
segment controls, sliders,
nav bars, switches.
Over two dozen widgets
that look like they
came right out of UIK.
But 100% open source.
If I have a question
about a text field,
I can go look at
its source code.
And you can't do that
with private API's.
Flutter makes executing
beautiful designs easy.
SPEAKER 1: Flair bridges
the gap between designers
and developers.
Designers are at last
able to fully participate
from beginning to end in
the development of an app,
creating interactive content
that can evolve along
with the rest of the app.
SPEAKER 4: Where
Flair really shines
is at building complex
animation systems that
are really easy to control.
We have full support for
bones, constraints, and inverse
kinematics.
SPEAKER 5: As you can see,
Flair removes the churn
between design and development.
And it really allows you to make
great design a fundamental part
of your process.
I'm really excited to announce
that Flair is launching today
on 2Dimensions.com,
and it's free.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 6: What we want to
do is show you something
a little different,
what it's actually
like to build a Flutter app,
what the developer experience
is like.
I wanted to build a retro clock
because I love my '70s chic.
SPEAKER 7: And I wanted
to showcase the fact
that we can use so
many different features
with our mobile phones.
So we're going to be
building a photo app,
because interactive
timers are the best.
SPEAKER 6: And what
I'm going to do
is I'm going to put in a stack.
And the reason I'm
using a stack is
that we can layer widgets on
top of each other with a stack.
And I'm going to start
with a wood grain.
SPEAKER 7: Oh there you go.
SPEAKER 6: Oh dear
me, it's wood grain.
Yes!
And there we go.
We have a card which
is kind of boring.
So let's make a
little more framing.
So I can give it a shape.
And I can give it a border.
And whoa, there we go.
Best clock ever.
Emily's done some funky
math, to basically say
every time we hit zero on
the seconds, take a picture.
And so we have managed to
squeeze in stacks, columns,
rows, and list views.
So we're going to
style up the time
and we're going to make
it not look super modern.
We're going to go art deco.
SPEAKER 7: So you see that?
If you tap the button, you
can see the text will change.
SPEAKER 6: Three, two, one.
Say cheese!
Oh look at that.
There we go.
[APPLAUSE]
Woo!
SPEAKER 8: I would like
to show you something cool
that we've been
adding to Flutter.
As you can see here, we
have an avatar of me.
And just like the timeline
app, the design animation
has been provided using Flair.
Close my eyes, tilt
right, and left.
It updates in real time.
SPEAKER 9: We believe
the economy is better
when everyone has access.
No one should be left out
because the cost is too high
or the technology too complex.
We started with a
little light reader
that let millions of merchants
participate in the economy
by making it easy
to take credit card
payments with your SmartPhone.
Now we've been following
Flutter since the beta.
And we're impressed by
how it enables developers
to quickly create beautiful and
perform at cross platform apps.
That's why today we're
so excited to announce
two new plugins for
Flutter development.
The Flutter plugin for
the square Reader SDK
and the Flutter plugin for
the In-App Payments SDK.
Collins Family Orchards is a
fourth generation family farm.
But they wanted to build
an app to accommodate
the specific needs of
their growing business.
This app helps them
take and track payments
at each farmer's
market they go to.
So let's say today that I'm at
a farmer's market in Bellevue.
Great, and I'll enter
the amount to charge.
And then I'll click Charge
to start the transaction.
And I'll insert my card
to take the payment.
Great!
And the payment was accepted.
Now when we look at that list of
transactions for this location,
we can see the payment that
I just took right there.
The Flutter plugin for
the square Reader SDK
is available today.
And the Flutter plugin for
the In-App Payments SDK
is available for early access.
SPEAKER 10: So I'm proudly
presenting you our brand
new product, codemagic.
And I'm going to
show how easy it
is to set up the whole
pipeline to build your Flutter
apps on codemagic.
It's very easy.
You just kick off
the first build.
You see the whole process
here on one screen.
So as I'm on Slack very
often, then of course,
I want my notification to
end up in Slack channel.
So I have chosen
here that I want
to know when the build
starts and when it fails.
Or when the artifacts
are published.
OK.
So you see that it's currently
building the Android app
and already you can open up
the steps to see everything
what's going on here.
You can also actually
[INAUDIBLE] your workflows.
So you know, I'm convinced
that Flutter plus codemagic
is the fastest route to get your
apps to the hands of your end
users.
So I invite everybody to join
and sign up at codemagic.io.
It's free.
It's live now.
[CHEERING]
SPEAKER 1: Flutter
was not conceived
as an SDK for iOs and Android.
Our vision for Flutter
is to be a portable UI
toolkit that can go wherever
you need to paint pixels.
The Flutter engine is
inherently cross platform.
And it can be embedded
in all kinds of hardware.
We believe Flutter is a useful
building block for these kinds
of embedded scenarios.
Another very practical
example of how
we are already
going beyond mobile
is Flutter Desktop Embedding.
This is an open
source project that
enables Flutter apps to run
on Mac, Linux, and Windows.
And in fact, when we were
putting this presentation
together, we were
thinking, how could we
make our slides as
beautiful as possible?
So we built the entire
presentation in Flutter.
There's one other
place we'd like
to go with Flutter that really
demonstrates the groundbreaking
potential of this technology.
We're calling this Hummingbird.
And it's a port of Flutter that
runs on the modern standards
based web.
Here's by simple mobile
app that we've been
running on an Android Tablet.
And everything
you're seeing here
is Flutter running on
the desktop web browser.
Importantly, it's
the same Flutter code
running in this browser
as on the phone.
In the meantime, we're
publishing right now
a blog article that describes
more of the technical details
behind Hummingbird.
And we'll have a lot more to
share at next year's Google I/O
Conference.
SPEAKER 11: So finally,
and really the whole reason
why I'm up here, is to
say a big thank you.
Thank you for taking time out of
your day to celebrate with us.
Flutter has always
been, and always will
be a community effort.
Built together, in the open,
no one company or one team
can reach all of the places
we want Flutter to go.
So we close with our hats
off to that community.
The stories like we're about to
show you give us the motivation
to continue each
day in this mission.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]